[Müzik]
Evet abesin Gülleri benim yavru
kurtlarım pembe panterler benim YKS tyt
AYT PTT ÖSS ÖYS eski adlarıyla bakalım
sonraki adı ne olacak o tayfam o
öğrencilerim Benim hele gelin toparlanın
dediniz ki ain gülü biz bu tarihi sen
böyle anlatıyorsun biz senden anlıyoruz
kolun kurbanın olam şu videoları bir çek
dediniz Ben de size dedim çekeceğim
Bugündü yarındı Haydi kalktı yan yattı
çamura battı derken Ahan da bugüne
nasipmiş Hadi Bismillahirrahmanirrahim
retro Yayıncılık bünyesinde yanlış
tarafa gösterdim retro Yayıncılık
bünyesinde Alın size YKS tyt AYT artık
neyse adı Ahanda ama şimdi Aa mebin
kitapları 9 10 11 12 Al sana ne güzel
set değil mi Ha Burada ünite adları
değişiyor şimdi mesela 9 sınıf kitabı
değişti güncellendi Tamam 10 11 12 aynen
devam işte Sonraki sene ne olacak 9lar
10'a geçtiğinde 10 sınıf kitabı
değişecek onla 10 sınıflar 11 olduğunda
11 değişecek böyle 4 yıllık bir süreçte
müfredat değişecek güncellenecek Tamam
tüme varım tümden gelim ne bilen ne
bilen ne bilen bir sürü teknikler
taktikler kullanılmış kitaplar şekilli
şembelek görsel hale getirilmiş içinde
etkinlikler bilmem neler işte QR kodları
Teknoloji ne ararsan hepsi mevcut hale
gelmiş ama
Eee ünite başlıklarını değiştirmişler
mesela 9 sınıflar için Tamam şöyle
başlıklara bakalım hemen 3 tane ünite
var 9 sınıf tarihinde tamam Ha burayı
Kıymetli kardeşlerim bak Sadece YKS AYT
tcert kıymetli tarih öğretmenlerim
sosyal bilgiler öğretmenlerim sınıf
öğretmenlerim Sizler de
dinleyebilirsiniz tamam mı ÖABT için
alan işleri için Tamam Aa burada ünite ü
tane var geçmişin inşa sürecinde tarih
eski çağ Medeniyetleri Orta Çağ
medeniyetleri Ç ünite var ama İslam
öncesi Türk tarihi diye ayrı bir başlık
MEB kitabında yok tamam İslam Tarihi
diye bir ayrı bir başlık yok hepsini
ünitelere eski Çağa şeye yedirmiş eski
çağ demiş İşte yönetenler askerler hukuk
din inanış Ne bileyim işte sanat sosyal
bilim falan demiş böyle işte Hem
anlatıyor işte Hunlar işte ne bileyim
İskitler beraberinde işte Urartular İşte
aklıma gelmiyor söylen Sümerler As babir
Hititler ik ller Lidyalılar Çin'i roma's
bilmem nesi değil mi Mısır uygarlıkları
bunları anlatıyor sonra dönüyor hukukta
bir daha anlatıyor işte işte yönetenler
asker de bir daha anlatıyor falan o
şekilde yapmış Ha biz tar öğretmenler
için arayıp da olam Mesela 10 sınıf
kitabında da mesela Tamam Osmanlı
tarihinde Osmanlı ile islan ilişkileri
diyor başlatıyor
1300'lü
mesela Tamam M işte Osmanlı Fransız
ilişkileri diyor baştan alıyor kanuniden
şeyden ta sonuna kadar götürüyor Benim
için arayıp bulamadığım bir şey ama işte
öğrenciye anlatırken aktarırken Burada
sıkıntılar yaşanıyor O yüzden ben
yıllarını verdiğim AB Bu tarihe Tamam
ben celalcaner2
amış ÖSYM Tamam tyt'de yok ama ayt'de
mutlaka bir iki soru geliyor mu Geliyor
neyle geliyor tarihin işte Tarih
biliminin yöntemleri İşte o ve bir de
şeyler bilim dalları ile alakalı
sorularla geliyor
şimdi kalemi bırak arkana yaslan Listen
to me çok very carefully Haydi
Bismillahirrahmanirrahim başlayalım
bakalım ünitenin adı eskiden beri ta
bizim gençliğimizden beri tarih bilimine
girişti şimdi ünitenin adı ne oldu
geçmişin inşa sürecinde tarih oldu gel
bu kamerad dayım Tamam gel Hah aferin
Aha bak Ark Yasan dinle tamam mı Beraber
abi kardeş gideceğiz Ben sana tarih
dersi ezber ezber ezber ezber Nah ezber
ezber falan değil abi her şeyin bir neyi
var mantığı var Ben sana o mantığı
anlattıktan sonra ki yapıyı da gördüm
zaten fitti fitti tamam retro Yayıncılık
hamdolsun bu sene bana at aldılar Kılıç
aldılar pelerin aldılar Ne bileyim kovuk
kaftan ne ne aklına ne geliyor hepsini
ald hatta kuvay-i Milliye şeyi bile dik
diktiriyor kendime tamam böyle yapacağım
dersleri de çok böyle uzatmadan Tamam 30
dakika 25 dakika 20 dakika olmuyor işte
düşmüyor neen inmiyor işte kurban
olduğum 25 30 dakika falan bitirmeyi
planlıyorum Niye Çünkü yeni nesil Sen
sen sen tamam mı Bu videoyu bakıyorsun
Oha 48 dakika bu ne ya dostum adamı
öldürüyorlar Ne bu diyorsun uzun geliyor
sana değil mi 202 dakikada bırakı
vereceğim lan reals izlerken bile mesela
geçiyor ya kısa öz net olacak Tamam Ark
yan Hadi bakalım tarihin tanımıyla başl
Ben bilmem tarih bilimine giriş geçmiş
İnşaat sürecinde tarih falan falan geç
ilk ünite Tamam tarih nedir tarihin
tanımı nedir what does History mean yap
Bana kendi tanımını ezberleme bu şundan
gelme geçmiş yaşamış insan yazmas geç
onu geç kitap tanımla Benim işim yok
tamam bu ezber değil bizimki mantık
anlayarak gideceğiz Mesela bana sor
tarih tanımı Sence tarih nedir diye
değil mi AB Bence tarih savaştır Bence
tarih türklerdir Bence tarih Orta
Asya'da Atın üstüne atlayıp
te altaylardan
tunaa altaylardan
tunaa Kızıl Çin arası var haydi yavrum
buraya Bence tarih budur değil mi Mesela
Sence tarih nedir sence tarih öğretmenim
Bence tarih kanuninin hürreme olan
aşkıdır Yavuz'un o cariyeye olan aşkıdır
merdü dieme Guy Zebun Etti Beni feleği
değil mi başkasına göre tarih hocam olur
mu ya illa buradan yerel düşünüyorsun
böyle milisin anladık da ya bu
Napolyon'un josephine olan aşkı ne
bileyim işte şeyin sezar'ın kleopatra'ya
olan aşkı Bilmem kimin nefertiti uğruna
yaptıkları falan hocam olur mu ya öbür
tarafta Çin setinin yapımı olur mu daha
avuç öbür bilinmedik keşfedilmedi
kıtalar var ne onlar Maya toltek astek
ink zıkkım Ne bilem ne falan filan değil
mi bak kendine göre bir tım oluştur
anlaştık ama ezberleme mantığı anla
tarihin tanımıyla alakalı biz mesela Eee
üniversitedeyken Tamam Mübahat Kütükoğlu
kitabı vardı tarihte usul diye mesela
Tamam onun gibi kitap vardı tarihin
tanımı 3,5 sayfa kurban olduğum
üniversite öğrencisiz 1 sınıfta bize
sorlar 3 sayfa yaz yaz yaz yaz yaz
bitmiyor ama tarihin tanımında olması
gereken 5 tane ana unsur var ne onlar
tarih kardeş yer bildiren bir bilimdir
Ama bu yer Dünya üzerinde gerçekten olan
gerçekten yaşanılmış bir yer olmak
zorundadır yoksa işte Anadolu'dur
asya'dır avrupa' değil mi Dünya üzerinde
var olan yaşanılmış bir yer olmak
zorundadır değil mi peki orta dünya olur
mu orta dünya hani var ya o şeyin
yüksükler efendisinde bak iş yüzükte mi
Hayır iş efendilikte değil mi Niye o
kadar izlendi o film efendiliğinden
izlendi bak yüksükler efendisinde orta
dünya diye bir yer var mordor isengard
minet mier dibi zıkkım Ne bilem ne e
bunlar var E böyle bir yer var mı yok
Peki onlar tarihe mi giriyor bilim
kurguya mı giriyor Bak onlar tarih değil
onlar neye giriyor onlar bilim kurguya
giriyor Anladın mı gerçekten yaşanılmış
bir yer olacak ve ikinci önemli
özelliğim tarih zaman bildiren bir
bilimdir Ama bu zaman geçmişte olacak
gelecekte olursa gene olmaz niye bilim
kurgu olur Biz şu an 2024 şeye gireceğiz
205'e Gireceğiz mesela değil mi Ee 2962
yılında Bak o bilim kurgunun işidir
Benim işim değildir o ne olacak geçmişte
yaşanmış gerçekten yaşanmış bir zaman
olacak peki Erler zamanı olur mu Orklar
zamanı bugün Vallah bugün Neyse şeye
takıldık yü efendisine takıldık Ha böyle
bir zaman var mı Yok gerçekten yaşanmış
yer ve zaman olacak Diğer türlü neye
girer bilim kurguya girer ve mutlaka
içinde ne olacak sebep sonuç ilişkisi
sebep sonuç neden sonuç işte işte Reason
result ne dersen de bak tarihteki bir
olay abi cim Bak bunlar birbirlerine
bağlıdır nasıl tesbih tanesi gibi
tesbih hemen uygulamalı görsel örnek Aha
tarin tespih tanesi gibi birbirine
bağlıdır Bu Audi halkaları gibi
birbirine bağlıdır tarihte Bir önceki
olay bir sonraki olayın sebebi bir
sonraki olay Bir önceki olayın sonucudur
değil mi Mesela ezberleme bak mantık
anla değil mi I Dünya Savaşı'nın sebebi
ne ya sayıyor bana kurban olduğum
Almanya'nın nazizm La oğlum öyle değil
la bir 2 Dünya Savaşı'nın sebebi ne 1
Dünya Savaşı niye 1 Dünya Savaşı'nda
Hesaplaşma işte bitmedi 2 Dünya Savaşı
oldu peki peki 1 Dünya Savaşı'nın sonucu
ne hı ik Dünya Savaşı İşte al birbirine
ne Bunlar bağlı ve bunları koparamazsın
O zaman ne olur anlamsız bütünlük
bozulur anlaştık birbirine bağlıymış O
yüzden sebep sonuç ilişkisi olacak ve
bir de belge olacak belge Peki belge ne
için lazım belge ne için lazım belge
olayların kanıtlanabilir liği için lazım
Ne kadar çok belge
kanıtla bilirlik için yani sen doğru mu
söylüyorsun atıyor mu işkembe-i kübradan
Sallıyor mu kardeş Belgen varsa
çıkarırsın ortaya Nah dersin korsun
anladın ve bir de ne olacak bir de
objektiflik olacak bu objektifliği
farklı farklı yazarlar tamam mı objektif
der nesnel der işte yansız der Anladın
mı objektif nesnel yansız tarafsız bir
sürü buradan ne çıkar kelime çıkar
objektif olacakmış ama tarihçinin iyisi
objektif olmaz Misal ben katien objektif
değilim ben niye olamam da kardeşim ya
açın bakın Avrupa'nın tarihini adamlar
atalarına toz kondurmuyor kurban oldum
ya Fransa'da 16 tane mi 20 tane mi de
loui var adamlar geliyor Kral bir birinc
l ikinc l 3üncü lüü 4C lüü brother Lui
lu lu Haydi yavrum lu lu Lui öyle gelmiş
herif bir icraatı yok bir şeyi yok ki
kurban oldu yani yapmamış ki isim
değiştirsin ama bizde Fatihler Yavuzlar
kanuniler atillalar alpanlar bizde
havalı uçuşur aslına nesline sövme Tamam
Bak mesela objektiflik budalalığın
yakalandığın zaman şöyle durumlar ortaya
çıkıyor şimdi sana soru 29 Mayıs 1453
salı günü sabah saat 05.30'da Tamam
Tursun Bey'in Ebul Fetih tarihinde
sadece orada geçer İstanbul'un fetih
saati Tamam biz bizans'ı İstanbul'u
Fetih mi ettik işgal mi ettik ver
bakayım cevap o işgal diyen ağzın üstüne
sunsu bir tane vurdun mu Vallahi burnun
ağzın şeye varı bak lan Ne işgali ne
fethettik diyeceksin fethettik değil mi
Hah Peki bize göre fethettik E hadi
objektif ol Onlara göre işgal ne
diyeceksin şimdi İstanbul'u Fetih mi
ettik işgal mi ettik Ee Feth ettik
dersen o objektif olmuyor işgal ettik
dersen aslına nesline sövüyor E ben ne
anladım bu işten ha bu olacakmış ama
bunu yandan böyle oale kullanacak mışın
Anladın mı objektiflik budalı
yakalanırsan aslına nesline söversin
elalemin dünya tarihinde adam atasına
nesline sövdüren o kadar sömürgeler
katliamlar yaptı Fransa o kadar
sömürgeler katliamlar yaptı hiçbir
tanesi geçiyor mu geçmiyor ama sana
sürekli laf atarlar dururlar ve kendi
tarihine sahip çıkacaksın sahip
çıkmazsan üstüne kon l a yunanlılarda
olduğu gibi işte Ne o işte yoğurt
ki mi baklava ki ne BİM işte fasulye ki
pl değil mi sirtaki onlardan bize
geçecek tek bir şey var O da ne ebenki
anladın sen anladın şimdi Bakal tarihin
tanımı bunlara bakarak tan bir ne
yapılır bir tanım yapılır tarih
ezberleme mantık anla ve 9 sınıflar
tavşanlar yazıldı birinci sorumuz bu Ben
olsam kesin Bunu sorarım yani hani
tarihin tanımında olan beş unsuru yazın
derim ben al Buna göre bir tanım yap
vereyim ben sana tarih geçmişte yaşanmış
insan olaylarının geçmiş insan bak
kriterlerim Bir de bunlar Tamam yer
zaman göstererek sebep sonuç ilişkisi
içinde belgelere dayanarak objektif
şekilde inceleyen bilim dalına ne
deniliyor muu tarih deniliyor musu
gördün mü illa bu beşi Mutlak surette
olacakmış anlaştık bak ezberleme
mantığını anla Tamam peki tarihin
özellikleri hemen geldik tarihin
tanımında bulunan beş özellik aynı
zamanda tarihin özelliğidir de geldim
orta kameraya Vazgeçtim o kameraya Al
beni ortaya
al biraz kameramanlar la uğraşayım ha
kameraman derken bizim Furkan nerede
askerde ha askerli de nereye çıktı
Isparta'ya benim Beyler beyliğe Aha bir
düdük yat bir düdük kalk bir düdük koş
bir düdük daha koş bir düdük Daha Hızlı
koş bir düdük iki kere sürün ya rabbel
alemin tabel Müslimin o kadar büyük ki
böyle elime avcuma geliyor mu Geliyor ya
Yaşasın kötülük edep Ha ya Sen ne güzel
bir şeysin bugün bütün gud duruklu
üstünde Vallah haberiniz olsun ha a
buradan tarihin tanımında bulunan 5
madde aynı zamanda tarihin Özeldir de
tarih yer Bildirir tarih zaman Bildirir
Tarihte sebep sonuç vardır belge Vardır
objektiflik vardır ama bir de tarihte
bilinecek en önemli özelliklerden birisi
tarihi olaylar abiciğim
tekrarlanamaz tamam mı tekrarlanamaz la
Bir kere oldu bitti gitti oldu bitti
gitti bize tarih olayı bak ha Tarih
tekerrürden ibarettir ama aynı olay
tekrar etmez benzer olaylar ne yapar
tekrar eder devlet kurulur yükselir
yıkılır ama aynı devlet tekrar kurulur
tekrar yükselir tekrar yıkılmaz Anladın
mı Hah Aynı olay tekrar etmez tarihi
olaylar
tekrarlanamaz yakışıklı tarihçiler bir
karizma tarihçiler Biz tarihçilerin
hasları tarihçi olsun 10 milyon fazla
olsun biz çılgın tarihçiler her şeyi
yaparız bizde ne
yok deney gözlem bizde katiyyen yoktur
olmayınca olmuyor Sen hiç şöyle bir
tartış gördün mü Vallahi olsaydı ben
kesin yapardım zaten şöyle bir tartış
gördün mü Evet Çocuklar Hadi bakalım
laboratuvara gidiyoruz deyip
laboratuvara hemen orada o piknik
tüpünün üstüne bir tane Can fanus şimdi
Can fanusu niye istediğimi anladın mı mı
arka taraf ha anladın bir tane Can fanus
böyle Hadi tüpü yakalım içine birazcık
Bizans'ın suyundan Biz ancık
Bizans'ın entrikası Bizans
imparatorunun sakalından Bir Tel biraz
Osmanlı ordusu biraz Fatih'in şahiden
toplarından bir parça biraz haliç'in
suyundan yak tüpü Hadi bakalım Karıştır
bir daha İstanbul'u F diyoruz deme
şansın var mı e yok ki bende deney
gözlem B her şey var deney gözlem yok
Niye Çünkü tarihi olay Aynen
tekrarlanmış Bundan dolayı biz
tarihçiler de ne de yok bizde şu da yok
Kesin kural kural ne lan Kendi hatamı
yazarken bile keşf Vallah buluyorum Bak
biz de kesin Kural Kaide kanun yoktur
Anladın mı yani her zaman aynı sonuç
olacak diye bir kaide yoktur Biz
ya ışığı açtım der ha inanmıyor musun
Kapat aç Kapat aç aç kapa ama yapar niye
der ki İşte buradaki manialı serbest
battığımız zaman elektrik devam eder
Oradan duydan gelir ışık yanar der
inanmıyorum Al tak tak tak tak tak tak E
biz Fatih İstanbul'u fethetti inanmıyor
mu E bir daha fet edelim deme şansın var
mı Yok işte bizde kesin Kural Kaide
yoktur benzer olaylar her zaman aynı
Sorucu verecek diye bir kaide yok mesela
İlla bir savaş olduğunda iki devlet
savaştı değil mi bak yani genel şey
yaparsak gen yaparsak iki devlet savaştı
biri yendi biri yenildi yemiyor Bazen
iki devlete karşı 3 devlet savaşıyor
bazen bir devlete karşı be devet
savaşıyor Osmanlı Haçlılar mesela
Anladın E ama her zaman biri yenecek
biri yenecek diye şey yok mesela tarihte
öyle savaş var ki abi berabere bitmiş Ne
o hepinizin bildiği o mısırlılarla
hititlerin tamam mı 16 yıl birbirlerini
yediler savaştılar Tamam sonunda Kadeş
Kadeş anlaşmasını imzaladılar tarih ilk
anlaşma diye geçiyor ya Kadeş
imzaladılar E sonuç hid de frik ikisi de
birden yıkıldı E hani biri yeniyordu
biri işe oluyordu anladın mı O yüzden
bizde kesin Kural Kaide yoktur İşte o
yüzden sana bir abi güzelliği Eğer bir
tarih sorusu çözüyorsun tamam mı tarih
sorusu çözüyorsun Ve o tarih sorusunda
paragrafın içinde cevapların içinde
şunlar varsa ne onlar Mesela en
hep
sadece tamamen
neamen tamamen tamam eniy le hepi le
aslan kaplan böyle iddialı şeyler
görürsen çiz gitsin tamam mı yanlıştır
Niye Çünkü tarihte Kesin bilgi yoktur
anlaştık değişebilir O yüzden Şuraya bak
Bir tane daha tik koymuşum Ne diyeceğim
oraya ha bu yeni mevcut bilgiler yeni
buluntular la yeni
buluntular mevcut bilgiyi mevcut bilgiyi
değiştirebilir
mi değiştirebilir mi Evet değiştirebilir
değiştirebilir komple değiştirebilir Bak
şimdi örnekler vereceğim Peki daha da
mevcut bilgiyi sağlamlaştıracak
örnekler vereyim size Tamam mesela Eee
Orhun Abideleri değil mi muhteşem üstü
adına yazıldı diye biliyorduk değil mi
Biz kimdi onlar Bilge Kaan değil mi
kültigin kardeşi Vezir Tonyukuk E hadi
hayırlı uğurlu olsun yazın yapılan
çalışmalarda İlteriş kaunda Yazıtı çıktı
Hadi hayırlı uğurlu olsun Al yeni bir
arkeolojik kazı her şeyi değiştirir
Mesela bizim Türk tarihimizde lolan
güzeli diye bir Mumya var Tamam ben
kafayı taktım ona yani bak geldiğim
zaman İsam sütan geldiğim zaman orada
anlatı vereceğim lolan güzelinde mumy da
piramit hepsinde orada bahı vereceğim al
değişebilir sağlamlaşır abilir O yüzden
bir soru çözerken şunları görürsen en
hep sadece tamamen yalnızca gibi bunları
ne yap Bunları sil tamam mı Bak iddialı
oluyor yani iddialı şeylerden kaç ucu
açık yorumları tamam mı daha böyle genel
Kaideler genel şeyler onları
işaretlemeye çalış eğer bak belli bir
seviyeye geldiğinde zaten tamam mı bazen
soruyu okumaya gerek bile kalmıyor
tarihte 5 seçenek mi var dördü bir
yanını gösteriyor biri bir yanını
gösteriyor Yeter ki belli seviyeye gel
Vallahi okumasın bile çıt işaret dersin
Ve seni sevdiğimden sana bir güzellik
daha şu ana kadar ÖSYM'nin yaptığı
sınavlarda Tamam bak ÖSYM'nin yaptığı
sınavlarda en çok cevap olarak gelen iki
şey en çok cevap olarak gelen iki şey
birincisi Merkezi Otoritenin korunması
Eğer şıklarda Merkezi Otoritenin korun
ını görüyorsan okuma okuma Yapıştır
gitsin işaretle kesin Doğrudur en çok
sorduğu bu kardeş bir devlet bunu
buradan alıp buraya koyduysa niye
yapıyordur Niye niye yapsın lan Merkez
otoritesini korumak için yapıyordur en
çok sorulan cevap olarak gelen bu
ikincisi ise İkincisi ise egemenlik
anlayışıdır
egemenlik bak çıkmış soruları Neyi
çözersen çöz tamam mı bunların en çok
cevap olarak geldiğini
gce al bunları gördün mü okuma gitsin
öğretmenim Peki şıklarda İkisi birden
varsa cevabın % ikisinden birisi gene
anladın bizde Avrupa'da var Yalan bizde
yalan yok Anlaştık Al bak soru tipi
demişken mesela tamamı al tarihin tanımı
hocam sen olsan bunu nasıl sorarsın ÖSYM
bunu bir kere sordu tamam mı tanım durum
sorusuyla
geldi tanım durum sorusu dedi ki tanımı
Az önceki tanımı verdi tarih geçmiş
yaşanmış insan olaylarını yer zaman
sebep sonuç belg inceleyen sosyal bir
bilimdir dedi tamam durum dedi tamam
başladı burada anlatmaya Anadolu'nun
türkleşme süreci malazgırt Bilmem neyle
başlamış olup şur ş olmuş ş falan
kitabında böyle anlatılmış filan da
böyle olmuş falan falan falan falan dedi
bir paragraf verdi Altına da şunu sordu
Dedi ki tanım durum değerlendirildiğinde
tanımda
verilenlerden hangisine durumda
değinilmemiştir diye sorar ÖSYM'nin
sorduğu soru buydu cevapta Genelde ne
olur biliyor musun cevapta genelde zaman
olur niye biliyor musun Bak ÖSYM seni
senden daha iyi tanıyor Senin
kaygılarını senin sazanlı ÖSYM Senden
daha iyi M Eğitim Bakanlığı Senden daha
iyi biliyor soruyu bir soruyor Anam
vallaha var ya böyle lan şey gibi
Göktürk Abideleri gibi uzun paragraf
veriyor uzatıyor da uzatıyor şimdi
öğrenci de çözüyor Ulan tarih sorusunda
tarih sorusunda ne olur ne olmaz lan
Tarihte yer olur mu Olur zaman olur mu
Kesin olur sebep belge yansız Mansız
falan diyor tamam mı Herifin kafayı
karıştırıyor öğrenci de genelde bunlara
düşüyor genelde tanım durum sorularında
cevap genelde Ne olurmuş cevap genelde
zaman olurmuş testleri çözmeye
başladığınızda dediğime geleceksiniz
abiniz biliyor bu işi al anlaştık bilin
Aha bizde kesin Kural kaide yok Yalnızca
en hep sadece tamamen bunları sallayıp
geçiyoruz Tamam beraberinde al gene en
önemli olaylardan birisi ve bir tarihi
olayı değerlendir ir Ken olayı günümüz
şartlarına göre değil günümüz günümüze
göre değil abiciğim olayın geçtiği
zamanın şartlarına göre değerlendirmeniz
lazım niye objektiflik için bu
gereklidir Nasıl ya Fatih Sultan Mehmet
bak olayı günümüze göre değerlendirirsek
geçmişteki Adamların hepsi saf olur
tamam mı Nasıl ya Fatih Sultan Mehmet
var ya Allah onda sırf burnuna bir de
Sakala çalışmış tamam mı ya İnanamıyorum
ya aman Allah'ım Tanrım ya Ya neden yok
karadan yürütmüş Ne bileyim işte böyle
Şah Ay ne uğraşmış
girseydim miş ya ihalarımız sihalar mızı
solo türkü gönderseydi ya Alp geymiş ya
Deme şansın var mı E bu olayı günümüze
göre değerlendirirseniz TKİ Adamların
hepsi saf olur yani Mustafa Kemal Paşam
e ya işte çıkmış da Samsun'a gitmiş
Havza Aman Ay ne uğraşmış Twitter'dan
etkinlik dürtmüş ya tiktok'ta bir işte
işte Real videosu atsay mış ya l o denir
mi o günümüze göre dilendiren geçmişteki
adamlar işte hiçbir şey yapmamış gibi
oluyor ulan Fatihi Fatih yapan Tamam
karadan gemiyi yürütmesi lan karadan
Gemi yürür mü e yürütüyor işte Paşa mı
Mustafa Kemal Paşa mı Paşa yapan nedir
Sen yokluklarla beraber sen çık
İstanbul'dan gel Samsun Havza Amasya
Erzurum bir milleti örgütle yeni en
baştan sıfırdan bir devlet kur anladın
olayı O yüzden günümüze göre değil o
dönemin şartlarına göre dendir meniz
lazım Bak eğer böyle olursa Neyi
kaybedersin objektifini kaybedersin
Mesela size bir İke
bir zaman mesela hop Çayımı da alalım
bak L 20 dakikadır ders anlatıyoruz bir
deniz demiyor ki hocam bir çay iç ya biz
de işte Bak sevdiğim zaman böyle tırt
gidiyor arkadaş Tamam Bayağı bir zaman
oldu tamam genci O zaman üniversite
öğrencisi falan dık Tamam tarihinle
alakalı bir program var Tamam orada bir
tane hocam anlatıyor Osmanlı ki Allah
aşkına Kur'an aşkına ilahi kelimetullah
aşkına emri bil maruf nehyi anil münker
aşkına Tekbir Allahu ekber falan
Osmanlı'yı anlatıyor anlatıyor anlatıyor
anlatıyor böyle biz de tabii Osmanlı
tarihçiyi ya biz de kuruluyor sanırsın
böyle tamam mı muç meydanında Kanuni
Sultan süleyman'ım sanırsın ki Ridaniye
Yavuz Sultan Selim Hanım lan tip de
benziyor Tamam böyleyim falan derken
telefonla birisi bağlandı dedi ki ya
hoca dedi sen böyle Anlatıyorsun
Anlatıyorsun ama dedi ee y dedi
Osmanlı'da dedi değişik İşler de varmış
dedi Nasıl yani Yah dedi işte elimde
benim bir tane dedi mektup var dedi bir
tane dedi belge var dedi Fatih'in
haremindeki Oğlan sayısı 4 müş dedi 4
Murat'ın anası mektup yazmış oğluna dedi
oğlum evlenirken oğlanları tercih et
demiş e o da gitmiş oğlanla evlenmiş
dedi E Osmanlıda değişik kişler var lan
Lan şimdi birden ortalık Ne oldu birden
değişti la havle ve la kuvvete dedik
Adam dedi ki evet dedi dediğiniz belge
Doğrudur dedi ben buradaki dedi
yanlışlığı düzelteyim dedi Aynen şunu
söyledi dedi ki bağlanabilir miyiz falan
Üniversitesinin filan Türk Dili bölüm
başkanına bağlanalım dediler bağlandılar
dedi ki Hocam dedi 16 yüzyıl 15 yüzyıl
Osmanlı türkçesinde oğlan ne demektir
diye sordu verdiği cevap Aynen şuydu el
bileği kalın ayak bileği kalın beli
kalın doğurganlık oranı yüksek şişman
tombiş tombalak kızlara Oğlan denirmiş O
zaman siz o kavramı günümüzde de
kullanıyorsunuz kız oğlan kız diyormuş
onun oğlanı nereden geliyor en başından
beri Öyleymiş işte Ama o dönem böyle
şimdi bak günümüzde mesela o sıfır beden
Kızlar evde kaldıydı Osmanlıda eski
Türklerde falan tamam mı evlenecek mi
böyle ne olman lazım suçlu kudretli
olman lazım Niye Çünkü Baba hıh anne hı
hıh doğacak çocuk hıh küp olacak ki
dünyaya hükmetsin kumu oturtsan anladın
E şimdi olayı günümüze göre değerlendir
seydike adamlar farklı şekilde
yorumlayabilir al bak objektiflik için
ne lazımmış olayı günümüze göre değil
nayin Davut neye göre değerlendirmek
lazımmış o dönemin geçtiği şartlara göre
değerlendirmek lazımmış Tamam bil bak
tarih böyle bir şey işte ya adam rezil
eder Vezir de eder hiç bilmezsin cahilli
yüzüne vuru verirler Tamam al ben her
şeyi öğreteceğim sana rahat ol sen
sıkıntı yok Tamam peki tarihin konusu ne
tarihin konusu ne işte Az önce dedik
işte savaşlar vuruşlar anlaşmalar bilmem
neler falan hepsinin konusu ne insan ve
insanın faaliyetleri anlaştık insan ve
insan faaliyetleri ama burada MEB
kitaplarında öncelerde vardı şimdiki
kitapta pek değinilmemiş şöyle bir durum
var doğa
olayları Doğa
olayları
afetler mesela depremler değil mi Bunlar
Teknik olarak tarihin konusuna girmez
Bunlar neye girer Bunlar coğrafyanın
konusudur ama ama şimdi oluşumu
bakımından oluşum bakımından tarihin
konusu değil ama etkisi bakımından
tarihin konusu mu tarihin konusu mesela
ülkemizde 6 Şubat'ta bir deprem oldu
değil mi on binlerce insanımızı Biz
orada kaybettik Allah gani gani rahmet
eylesin Ha o deprem coğrafyanın konusu
ama orada ölen insanlar işte tarihin
konusu oluyor anlaştık bilin bununla
alakalı tartışmalar devam ediyor doğal
afetler var mı yok mu Çünkü günümüze
geldikçe daha fazla şeyler oluyor Yani
onunla alakalı tartışmalar var Sor Bakal
çok karşınıza geleceğini zannetmiyorum
web kitabından da çıkardılar zaten Tamam
peki bir de burada geldim bu kameraya
geldim Ne var olay olgu meselesi var
ÖSYM bunu da sordu çıkmış soruları
çözdüğünüz de göreceksiniz şu Ne lan bu
olay ne bu ol kitaplar anlatır yazıl
hocam sorar zaten tamam mı A olay
anlıktır orgu süreçtir abi işte biri
kısa süreli biri uzun süredi biri somut
biri soyut biri Özgün biri genel böyle
anlaşılmıyor Abi şöyle bileceksin mesela
bunu da ösm sorduğu soru Aynen Buydu
işte 1071 Malazgirt Savaşı tarihi olaya
örnektir 26 Ağustos 1071 Cuma günü saat
14.00'da ben de oradaydım Tamam aha
bizim Alparslan'ın Beyazlar içindeki
Alparslan'ın arkasında Bizler dedik ki
Alparslan siz size öyle bir memleket
alacağım ki ilelebet sizin olacak dedi
hücum dedi Biz Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah koşturmaya başladık işte 4
be saat içinde de karşıdaki Bizans
sorusunu perişan ettik geçtik al oldu
bitti gitti bu ne bu olgu şey bu olay
anlaştık anlık bir şey oldu bitti gitti
ama bundan sonra 1071'den sonra
Alparslan ne dedi gidin fethedin
fethettiğiniz yer sizin olsun dedi bir
süreç başladı ne süreci Anadolu'nun Türk
leşmesi süreci başladı işte bu ne bu bir
süreç bu uzun süreli bak malazgırt
Savaşı kısa sürede oldu bitti gitti ama
Anadolu'nun türkleşmesi Bak bu bir
olguyu anlaştık Buraya mesela genelde
savaşlar anlaşmalar ne oluyor olay
oluyor anlık yapılıyor imzalanıyor
bitiyor gidiyor anladın ama onun
getirdiği onun getirdikleri ne oluyor
süreç oluyor anlaştık mesela
cumhuriyetin ilanı bak olay değil mi ama
cumhuriyetin laikleşmesi değil mi
inkılap hareketlerinin yapılması bak bir
süreçle geliyor anlaştık nokta atışı
bilgilerle Ahanda tarihin
özelliklerinden deil mi genel
yapılarından bahsettik soru tiplerini
verdik olay olguyu verdik Gel ortaya
Tamam genel yapısıyla bu işte bu kadar a
yarım saat Yarım saat a çeki Vereceğim
videolarınızı bitecek gidecek çıt çıt
çıt çıt çıt çıt çıt işaretleyip
geçeceksiniz Tamam Ahan da retro
yayıncılıkta burada bir D şeylerimiz var
Tamam tarih ABS YouTube kanalında da
yazılı çalışmaları falan çeki verdim
Oraya da oradan da bakarsınız bitti
gitti had Hazırlığını yap ikinci ders
aynen devam tarihin özelliklerini
bitirdik değil mi şimdi Sırada ne var
bekle az sonra Haydi sonraki ders
Görüşürüz
[Müzik]